FOREVER.
GREG GUTFELD TAKES IT ALL FROM
YOUR.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
FACING.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE IF I WERE A REPUBLICAN
RUNNING, I WOULD SAY DEMOCRATS
CAN'T PROTECT US ACROSS THE
WORLD, DEMOCRATS CAN'T PROTECT
OUR STREETS AND DEMOCRATS CAN'T
PROTECT US AT THE BORDER.
>> Greg: THAT'S HOW BAD THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING.
JOE SCARBOROUGH IS A REPUBLICAN
AGAIN.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
>> Greg: SUPER-DUPER
WEDNESDAY, EVERYONE!
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST
RELEASED AN AD AND IT'S REALLY
SOFT ON PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> President Biden: AMERICA IS
BACK.
>> HIGHEST INFLATION RATE.
>> THE BORDER IS COLLAPSING, THE
CLIMB INS COVID COLLECTIONS.
>> President Biden: WE
AMPLIFIED OUR POWER, SOME AT NEW
STRENGTH BURIED >> SHOULD WE BE
EMBARRASSED?
>> LIPOMAS HE IS BACK.
>> KABUL IS NOT AN IMMINENT
THREAT ENVIRONMENT.
>> President Biden: THE
LIKELIHOOD THERE'S GOING TO BE
THE TALIBAN OVERRUNNING
EVERYTHING AND OWNING THE WHOLE
COUNTRY IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY.
>> Greg: DID I SAY SOFT?
SORRY ABOUT THAT, THAT WAS AS
SOFT AS CHRIS CUOMO'S SKULL.
MEANING NOT SOFT AT ALL.
THAT'S IF CHRIS CUOMO IS
WATCHING.
I DIDN'T REALLY WATCH THESE
VIDEOS BEFORE I DO THE SHOW
INSTEAD OF DOING SHOTS OF HAND
SANITIZER WITH KAT.
AND AMERICA, PLEASE DON'T SAY I
TOLD YOU TO DRINK HAND
SANITIZER, SAY KAT DID.
SO LET'S HAVE ANOTHER TASTE,
SHALL WE?
>> THEY OWN THE WHOLE COUNTRY
NOW.
THE TALIBAN ARE NOW IN COMPLETE
CONTROL.
>> HOW DID PRESIDENT BIDEN GET
THIS SO WRONG?
>> FIRST OF ALL, OUR MISSION
HASN'T FAILED.
YET.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU THINK I'M
SATAN REINCARNATED.
DO I BEAR RESPONSIBILITY?
ZERO RESPONSIBILITY.
>> CHINA IS READY FOR FRIENDLY
RELATIONS WITH THE TALIBAN.
>> [INDISCERNIBLE].
>> WE HAVE TO ASK THE TALIBAN
FOR PERMISSION FOR AMERICAN
CITIZENS TO LEAVE, TRUE OR NOT
TRUE?
>> THEY ARE IN CONTROL.
>> President Biden: I CAN'T
RECOMMEND ANYONE BETTER TO LEAD
THIS OPERATION --
>> THEY ARE JUST CHANTING TO
AMERICA.
>> Greg: WELL, MUCH LIKE THE
WAHLBERG PARENTS, I FEAR THAT
WILL LEAVE A MARK.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
>> OH!
>> Greg: THOUGHT IS A REALLY
TERRIBLE JOKE, AND I'M SO PROUD
OF IT.
THAT VIDEO SAYS WHATEVER WHEN
OUTSIDE THE MEDIA THINKS, THAT
JOE IS A HUMAN TEA BAG AND HE'S
ALWAYS IN HOT WATER.
WE SAW YESTERDAY'S HORRIBLE
SPEECH, IT HAD THE INTIMIDATING
POWER OF A REFRIGERATOR MAGNET.
IT WAS AS INSPIRATIONAL AS THE
LIST OF SIDE EFFECTS IN A DRUG
COMMERCIAL.
IS ENERGIZING IS EATING A POUND
OF PASTA AFTER A STACK OF
PANCAKES AND CHASING THAT WITH A
FISTFUL OF XANAX.
HE ANSWERED YOUR QUESTIONS THAN
THE TALIBAN AND SPLIT FASTER
THAN [INDISCERNIBLE]'S PANTS ON
DOUGHNUT DAY.
WHILE ALL MINDS WERE ON
AFGHANISTAN, WHAT DID BIDEN LEAD
WITH?
PROGRESSIVE'S GREATEST HITS, ALL
AIMED AT US AND NOT THEM.
OF >> President Biden: TODAY'S
VOTE IN THE HOUSE ALLOWED THEM
TO CONSIDER MY BUILD BACK BETTER
AGENDA, A BROAD FRAMEWORK TO
MAKE HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE,
PROVIDE TWO YEARS OF UNIVERSAL,
HIGH-QUALITY PRE-K AND TWO YEARS
OF FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
MAKING INFRASTRUCTURE MORE
RESILIENT TO THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND SO MUCH MORE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO VOTED TO SUPPORT THE
JOHN LEWIS VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
YOU KNOW, ADVANCING -- IT'S AN
ACT TO RESTORE AND EXPAND VOTING
PROTECTIONS, TO PREVENT VOTER
SUPPRESSION, AND TO SECURE THE
MOST SACRED OF AMERICAN RIGHTS,
THE RIGHT TO VOTE FREELY, THE
RIGHT TO VOTE FAIRLY, AND THE
RIGHT TO HAVE YOUR VOTE COUNT.
>> Greg: SO FIRST YOU GOT FREE
STUFF, WHICH AT LEAST DIDN'T GO
TO THE TALIBAN.
STILL, IT'S SORT OF LIKE WHEN
YOU'RE WIFE GIVES YOU A
CHRISTMAS GIFT BOUGHT WITH YOUR
MONEY.
SORRY.
OUR MONEY.
EXCEPT HERE IT LEADS TO
INFLATION AND UNEMPLOYMENT.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
THANK GOD SHE'S NOT WATCHING.
WE GOT VOTER SUPPRESSION WITHOUT
ANY EVIDENCE THAT IT EXISTS.
WE GOT CLIMATE CHANGE, WHICH
MUST BE GOOD NEWS FOR THE
TALIBAN, BECAUSE ACCORDING TO
"NEWSWEEK," THE TALIBAN IS NOW
VOWING TO FIGHT GLOBAL WARMING,
WHICH, YOU KNOW, I DON'T DOUBT.
EVERYBODY AGREES ONE BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IS OVERPOPULATION
AND YOU CAN ARGUE NO ONE HAS
DONE MORE TO BRING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ON THIS PLANET DOWN THAN
THE TALIBAN, AT THE RATE THEY
KILL PEOPLE, CARBON EMISSIONS
WON'T BE A PROBLEM IN A COUPLE
OF MONTHS.
BUT THAT'S THE THING WITH JOE'S
PRESSERS.
DOES HE EVER HAVE A REAL ANSWER?
TO SEE JUST PLAY WITH HIS WHEEL
OF EXCUSES?
>> THIS IS HOW WE GET READY FOR
A PRESS CONFERENCE.
HERE WE GO.
YOU HAVE TO ASK JEN PSAKI.
SHE'S GOOD.
LOOK, I INHERITED THIS THING,
ALL RIGHT?
NO, NO.
PEOPLE ARE WEARING THEIR MASKS.
THAT WAS LIKE FOUR OR FIVE DAYS
AGO.
COME ON, MAN!
ASK THAT AGAIN BUT JUST CHANGE
THE WORDS.
JUST WALK AWAY.
THAT'S ME.
I'VE GOT TO JUST WALK AWAY.
HERE WE GO.
JUST SORT OF WALK AWAY.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HERE'S THE WEIRDEST
THING.
HOW DOES EVERYONE ELSE KNOW THE
RIGHT THING TO DO EXCEPT THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE?
I GET IT, THERE IS NO SUCH THING
AS A CLEAN SOLUTION, BUT THE
EXECUTION BEGAN WITH A PLOT
PREMISE, IT'S THE PRISON OF TWO
IDEAS, WE STAY FOREVER OR WE GET
OUT.
SOUNDS A LOT LIKE MARRIAGE.
BUT YOU COULD HAVE REDEFINED THE
MISSION THE WAY FOOTBALL COACH
MAKES ADJUSTMENTS AT HALFTIME OR
IN THIS CASE, LATE IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER.
YOU COULD HAVE LEFT THE PLACE IN
THE RIGHT ORDER, AMERICAN
CITIZENS FIRST, ALLIES AND
TROOPS.
SERIOUSLY, HOW CAN WE CALL THE
TALIBAN BACKWARD WHEN EVERYTHING
WE DID WAS BACKWARD?
YOU COULD HAVE BLOWN UP ALL THE
STUFF SO WE DIDN'T BUILD THEM A
NEW ARMY FREE OF COST BURIED I
BELIEVE THAT'S ON PAGE TWO ON
HOW TO WIN AWARD FOR DUMMIES.
SO WHY IS THIS SO EASY FOR A
CHUCKLE BUCKET LIKE ME TO COME
UP WITH?
A CHUCKLE BUCKET STILL DRUNK ON
CAT'S HANNAH TIES HER -- HAND
SANITIZER.
MAYBE IT'S JUST HARDER FOR JOE.
JOE EFT IT UP JUST LIKE OBAMA
AND OSAMA SAID HE WOULD, LIKE
HE'S AFT UP EVERYTHING.
THE LIKELIHOOD THERE'S GOING TO
BE THE TALIBAN OVERRUNNING
EVERYTHING AND OVERRUNNING THE
COUNTRY IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY?
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T REMEMBER
SAYING THAT.
THERE'S -- IT'S THAT WE ELECTED
SOMEONE WHO COULDN'T PRESIDE
OVER THE CHANGING OF HIS SOCKS
MUCH LESS THE CHANGING OF A
GOVERNMENT.
FIFTH-GRADERS COULD BEAT HIM IN
A GAME OF RISK, BUT WE CAN'T
BLAME HIM, HE NEVER HID HIS
INCOMPETENCE.
HE'S THE EPITOME OF THE INSIDE
THE BELTWAY SPONGE SOAKING UP
ALL THE PERKS.
HE WAS MORE FOR SALE AND TVs
BEFORE THE SUPER BOWL.
THE BLAME GOES TO THE MEDIA WHO
PAPERED OVER HIS BOTTOMLESS
INCOHERENCE, WHO PRETENDED THERE
WAS NOTHING WEIRD ABOUT A
CANDIDATE WHO BARELY CAMPAIGNED
FROM HIS BASEMENT, WHO BURIED
THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP STORY,
WHO PORTRAYED TRUMP AS THE REAL
UNSTABLE END.
THIS FROM DEEP STATE GENIUSES
FROM OR WRITE LESS OFTEN THAN A
COLLEGE FOOTBALL PLAYER ON HIS
S.A.T.s.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT SURE IF I
COULD EVEN BLAME THE AFGHAN
PRESIDENT FOR SCREAMING, LACKING
FAITH INVITING VERSUS KNOWING
WHAT THE TALIBAN WILL DO TO YOU,
WHAT'S YOUR CHOICE?
I WAS WITH THE BIGGEST BONEHEAD
MOVE OF ALL IS THINKING THE
GOVERNMENT COULD HOLD OFF THE
TALIBAN FOR MONTHS.
I MEAN, WHY FIGHT WHEN THE GUY
BACKING YOU HAS LESS JOB
SECURITY THAN THE INCOMING HOST
OF JEOPARDY?
HOW DID THEY MISS THAT WHEN IT
WAS AS OBVIOUS AS THE WAKE ON
BRIAN KILMEADE'S HEAD?
SO IT COMES DOWN TO ONE WORD,
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE NEED TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
CORRUPTION AS WELL AS THE
INCOMPETENCE.
WE NEED TO ASK HOW THEY CAME TO
THIS STRATEGY.
WAS IT BASED ON THE MEMO RATHER
THAN ON MEN?
WAS IT BASED ON CONSENSUS RATHER
THAN REALITY?
WHOSE OPINIONS MATTERED MOST AND
WHY?
WHO SCOFFED AT A RAPID TALIBAN
TAKEOVER?
MAYBE NONE OF THEM SCOFFED AT IT
AND THEY WERE LYING TO US ALL
ALONG.
SO NOW WE'VE ABANDONED THOUSANDS
OF ALLIES.
SOMETHING I COULDN'T SEE TRUMP
DOING.
ODDLY, BEING AMERICA FIRST OFTEN
HAS THE SECONDARY EFFECT OF
HELPING THOSE WHO HELP US.
THAT'S RIGHT, MEDIA, THE GUY YOU
CALLED HITLER FOR FOUR YEARS HAD
MORE COMPASSION THAN ANY OF YOUR
DUMB IDEAS OVER THE LAST DECADE.
SO INSTEAD WE WENT FROM AMERICA
FIRST TO BIDEN'S ARE AMERICA'S
WORST.
IT'S NO BUILD BACK BETTER, JUST
MORE ACCURATE.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUEST!
COHOST KAYLEIGH McENANY!
SHE IS SUCH A STRONG ANCHOR, WE
USE THEM TO DOCK MY YACHT ON THE
WEEKEND, FOX BUSINESS
CORRESPONDENT SUSAN LI!
HE'S SO HANDSOME, OTHER MARINES
CALL HIM SEMPER FINE.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JOHNNY JOEY
JONES!
FINALLY, SHE'S GOT THE VOICE OF
AN ANGEL IF THAT ANGEL SMOKED A
PACK A DAY FOR 30 YEARS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF!
SO I GUESS I SHOULD GO TO THE
VETERAN FIRST, KAT.
>> I'M ONLY HALF.
>> Greg: THAT'S RIGHT.
SO, JOEY, HOW DID WE GET THIS SO
WRONG AND CAN WE FENCE THIS?
I SHOULD ASK YOU, YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING TO A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THE MILITARY, HOW DO THEY FEEL
ABOUT THIS?
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE I'M TALKING
TO ARE WORKING TO GET PEOPLE OUT
OF AFGHANISTAN, IT MAY BE
PRESIDENT BIDEN SHOULD, I DON'T
KNOW, TAKE NOTES, GIVE THEM A
CALL.
I'VE GOT SOME NUMBERS, COULD
GIVE THEM A CALL.
LOWER LEVEL OFFICERS AND
MID-LEVEL ENLISTED ARE WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK TO GET THEIR
INTERPRETERS AND THEIR
INTERPRETER FAMILIES --
>> Greg: ARE THOSE PRONOUNS?
IS NOT UPON?
>> MY PRONOUNS ARE HEE AND HAW.
LAST TIME I WAS ON HERE I GOT
BACKED ONTO THE CORNER ON THE
STUFF.
I'M NOT A CULTURAL REPORTER
HERE, OKAY?
I'M BEYOND UPSET.
I FEEL BETRAYED.
YOU KNOW, I TWEETED -- THE
TALIBAN BROKE MY BODY BUT THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT BROKE
MY HEART ON THIS, RIGHT?
WEEK SACRIFICED A LOT, AND
THAT'S OKAY.
MY SACRIFICE WAS JUSTIFIED THAT
IT HAPPENED BECAUSE OTHER PEOPLE
CAME HOME THAT DAY AND LIVED,
BUT WE'VE GOT MEN AND WOMEN
SERVING RIGHT NOW AND I COULDN'T
IMAGINE BEING THERE EITHER ON
THAT FLIGHT LINE IN KABUL WERE
SITTING ON A BASE SOMEWHERE HERE
KNOWING YOU COULD BE CALLED UP
NEXT, KNOWING THAT THIS IS WAS
GOING TO HAVE YOUR BACK, BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY WHO ISN'T.
AND LOOK, ON THE EXCUSES PART,
THIS IS THE ONLY PRESIDENT
REALLY THAT DID NOT INHERIT THIS
WAR.
BECAUSE EVEN WHEN
GEORGE W. BUSH, YOU COULD SAY
IT'S INCOMPETENCE OF THE
CLINTON, THEY COULD HAVE
SQUASHED THIS THING TO BEGIN
WITH AND PRETENDED TO TRY.
BUT JOE BIDEN WAS
VICE PRESIDENT.
HE HELPED PRESIDE OVER THE
DISASTER THAT WAS IRAQ.
HE OPPOSED THE TROOP SURGE,
WHICH WAS THE SECOND TIME WE RAN
THE TALIBAN OUT OF THE COUNTRY,
JUST FOR OBAMA TO CLAIM VICTORY
FOR 2012, NOT ACTUALLY WIN THE
WAR.
I KNOW THAT WELL, I SACRIFICED A
COUPLE LEGS FOR THAT, YOU'RE
WELCOME, OBAMA.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
I'LL GIVE THAT TO YOU, BUD, BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THIS GUY
WAS VICE PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT
YEARS OF THIS WAR AND YOU WANT
TO SAY YOU INHERITED A
SITUATION?
LIKE, COME ON, MAN.
>> Greg: YOU QUOTED HIM JUST
THERE, COME ON, MAN.
SO THERE'S TWO THINGS I WANT TO
ASK YOU.
ONE IS -- OKAY, SO JOEY'S
QUESTION ABOUT INHERITING
SOMETHING, THEY ALWAYS SAY TRUMP
STARTED THIS.
BUT THERE IS SOMETHING GOING ON
THERE THAT'S NOT BEING HONEST.
AND I JUST WANT TO ASK YOU, AND
I HATE MIND-READING AND
HYPOTHETICALS, BUT COULD YOU
VENTURE WHAT MIGHT'VE BEEN
DIFFERENT IF TRUMP WERE
REELECTED?
HOW WOULD HE HAVE DONE THIS
DIFFERENTLY?
I KNOW THAT'S KIND OF HARD TO
DO.
>> IT'S NOT HARD TO DO.
IT'S VERY EASY.
I SPOKE TO HIM YESTERDAY, HE
WOULD NEVER HAVE HAD AN ACCIDENT
LIKE THIS.
HE SAID YESTERDAY WE MANAGED TO
GET AFGHANISTAN UNDER CONTROL
WITH 2,500 TROOPS, IT WAS A
MEASURED WITHDRAW, BIT BY BIT TO
WHERE WE HAD IT SECURE.
HE CAME CLOSE TO WANTED TO PULL
OUT OUR TROOPS SEVERAL TIMES,
BUT HE LISTENED TO THE GENERALS.
HE LISTENED TO THOSE AROUND HIM
AND NEGOTIATED A
CONDITIONS-BASED WITHDRAWAL.
NOT ONLY THAT, THE TALIBAN
FEARED PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY LOOKED AT WHAT HAPPENED TO
SOLO MONEY.
THEY LOOKED AT WHAT HAPPENED
WITH SYRIA CASTING ITS OWN
PEOPLE.
HE TOOK ACTION.
HE'S A MAN OF ACTION AND NOW YOU
HAVE A BUFFOON AS OUR COMMANDER
IN CHIEF.
HE VACATIONS IN DELAWARE, HE
DOESN'T TAKE QUESTIONS, HE TURNS
HIS BACK ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND HE IS A SURRENDER OR IN
CHIEF.
WE HAVE SURRENDERED AND THE
TALIBAN IS DICTATING
UNITED STATES FOREIGN POLICY,
THE MOST POWERFUL COUNTRY ON
EARTH.
THIS IS PATHETIC AND BIDEN'S
DIRECTOR WAS POSSIBLE.
>> THE NEW TALIBAN.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I THINK YOU WERE
UNFAIR TO THE TALIBAN.
SUSAN.
>> THAT'S TOUGH.
THAT'S PRETTY TOUGH.
>> Greg: WHAT ABOUT ALL THE
WEAPONS, THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS -- WAS IT BILLIONS?
>> TRILLIONS.
2,000 LIVES THAT WERE LOST OVER
THE LAST 20 YEARS AND AGAINST
HIM.
>> Greg: OH CORPORATION,
WORKING THE BUSINESS ANGLE.
BECAUSE VERY GOOD.
>> Greg: A SHIFT IN TRANSFERS.
PEOPLE WOULD BE FIRED.
NO ONE IS RESIGNING!
>> THE STOCK WOULD GO TO ZERO.
ACTUALLY THAT WAS THE CASE, SO
IT'S A LOSS, RIGHT?
NERD TO NERD, HAD TO SAY THE ONE
GOOD PART OF THIS WHOLE STORY.
>> Greg: ARE YOU CALLING ME A
NERD?
>> I'M CALLING THE AFGHANI
ROBOTICS TEAMS A NERD.
I'M A NERD.
I REALLY FEEL BAD FOR THE WOMEN
IN AFGHANISTAN BECAUSE THESE ARE
WOMEN THAT ACTUALLY HAD A TASTE
OF FREEDOM AND A TASTE OF
EDUCATION FOR THE LAST 20 YEARS
BUT HOW DO YOU TELL YOUR
DAUGHTERS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROMISED A CAREER IN PROMISED
EDUCATION THAT THAT'S NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN ANYMORE?
YOU HAVE A YOUNG DAUGHTER,
RIGHT?
>> YEAH, JOEY HAS TALKED ABOUT
LIFE UNDER THE TALIBAN.
I CANNOT IMAGINE.
I CANNOT SIMPLY IMAGINE.
YOUR CHILD'S LIFE, NOT EVEN
THEIR LIKELIHOOD, THEIR LIFE.
>> THE NEW TALIBAN.
>> Greg: HOW DO YOU FEEL A BUT
THE NEW TALIBAN?
>> I THINK IT'S SO INTERESTING
THE WAY WE ARE EVEN HAVING THE
DISCUSSION, LIKE HAVE THEY
CHANGED?
I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE THEY'VE
CHANGED, MAYBE THIS IS THE NEW
TALIBAN WHEN WE DON'T GET THAT
GRACE TO LET CHRIS HARRISON FROM
THE BACHELOR.
>> GOOD POINT!
>> HE WAS FIRED FOREVER, BUT WE
ARE LIKE MAYBE THE TALIBAN HAS
CHANGED.
AT THIS -- YOU KNOW, IF WE'RE
DOING THINGS THIS WAY, THE
TALIBAN HAS A BETTER CHANCE OF
HAVING A COOKWARE LINE AT TARGET
THEN CHRISSY TAKEN.
>> Greg: THAT IS SO TRUE!
THAT IS SO TRUE.
THINK ABOUT IT YET, COULD
ACTUALLY HOST JEOPARDY.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO GIVE THEM
PRESSURE HOOKS.
[SCATTER